You need to stop eating In-N-Out. I
watched you. Shake Shack and In-N-Out,
bro. You you've been watching me. You
got cameras in here?
I watched you. Every day I think about
how I'm going to cook you. I'm going to
follow I'm going to put you in an
In-N-Out Burger, bro. Every day. Every
day. I'm Middle Eastern, okay? You never
know. One day you might be a donair
kebab. The first point is the is is as
follows.
Christians attempt, in their best will
and and interest, to replicate the
teachings and life of Jesus Christ,
correct? That's point number one.
Okay? You intend to live as he did,
okay? That's point number one. Point
number two, we as Muslims believe that
Allah God has provided this new book to
clarify
matters of the past and of the present
and future, okay? So, there are two
different things happening here, okay?
Number one, you Christians want to
emulate Jesus. You want to reach as
close to him as possible. Therefore,
logically, you would follow exactly as
he did, not what Paul tells you to do,
okay, which is an aberration. Should
Should we be crucified on crosses, too?
Don't you believe your original
followers were?
And I never said all of them. I never
said all of them. They shouldn't They
didn't They didn't They didn't look
forward to that. They didn't They didn't
go, "Hey guys, crucify me on a cross
because my Lord
you venerate you you venerate them as
martyrs, correct? They are martyrs, but
that's You're not You're missing the
question. Should we as Christians, since
we should do everything that Jesus did,
should we
all you Is that not all what you
believe? Is that all what you believe?
go and get and go and get crucified?
That is not something you do. That is
something done to you. No, but Jesus
willingly went. Jesus willingly went to
them and and said,
Yes, he gave his life as a ransom for
many. Should we do that? According to
you, to fulfill the prophecy. That's not
the same thing as you willfully going
and stabbing yourself in the hand on a
cross. That's not the same thing. Why
why not Why don't I have somebody else
do it? Why don't Since I Since my Lord
was crucified, why not I have Why don't
I have somebody
put nails in my hands and nail me to a
cross and leave me there? You know you
you come on Come on, God logic. You know
the argument you're making is very
facetious. You know what you're doing
right now. Come on. No, so no, I'm I'm
showing you that I'm showing you that
your understanding of Christianity and
what you're the standard that you're
trying to apply to us is is faulty. We
just Jesus is our Lord, yes. We obey his
teachings, yes. But we don't do every
little thing that he's that he did.
That's crazy. Okay. First of all, yes,
you If Jesus walked with his
uh 2 in with his left foot and 3 in with
his right, obviously you wouldn't expect
to copy the exact movement of his feet
just as he did, okay? However, however,
Jesus your belief is that he was a Jew,
okay? No, that's what you said. We both
believe he was a Jew. We also believe he
was ethnically a Jew. All right. We're
on the same page and we get that from
the Bible, right?
No. No. Copying the way he walked,
that's a very That's an OCD matter,
okay?
The matter about dietary law, that is
something that is part of the community,
part of the faith. It's everyone agrees
with it, all right, around that time who
is a Jew, okay? So, it's not the same
thing. It's not the same thing. I'm
going to let you continue. Just quick
question. It's not even on subject, but
just quick question. I'm not going to
even fuss with you.
Are you familiar with Like, isn't there
a particular foot that you're supposed
to walk in the bathroom with because
Muhammad walked in the bathroom a
certain way? Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
So you So you
And and and into the mosque as well,
yes. Right. So So like you say That's
interesting. So you Like you say like,
"Oh, well, if you're do like walk in
certain steps that Jesus stepped in and
how he walked, yada yada," that would be
like OCD type stuff, but this is in your
religion. No, there's a complete
difference because this is a This I'm I
When I gave the example previously, I'm
talking about literally you're literally
thinking of literally every step the
step you take when you're walking around
the world, right? That's all you have to
say. But when you walk into a mosque and
you push your right foot forward first,
this is a symbolic gesture. This is a
meaningful gesture. This is not
something where you're OCD thinking
every step you take in your life,
counting every step. I I I can I can
understand the thing about the masjid
thing. If there has If there's
significance to that, but what about the
bathroom? Like, why why have to Why do
you have to walk into the bathroom with
your right foot first just cuz Muhammad
did? What do you mean? It's sunnah. We
copy that practice. But is there like
what's the significance? I know around
the matter of eating with the the the
right hand and and and Sorry, eating
with the with one certain hand and
shaking hand with the other hand. I
don't know regarding the bathroom matter
of the foot, okay? I'm uneducated on the
matter about the bathroom. Fair enough.
Fair enough. All right, let's let's
continue to get back on topic. That was
just a little side little little
sidebar. But go go ahead. You was
Finish your point if you I hope I didn't
distract you too much. No, you threw me
off my goddamn point. I'm sorry for
blaspheming Sorry for blaspheming. Yeah,
the example you gave about crucifixion,
I'm sorry. It is a very bad example
because as I I agree. What do you mean
you agree? You made the example. You
gave the example. No, what I'm saying is
it's a bad example because the standard
that you was applying on me was bad. We
should do everything that Jesus ever
did, but no, we shouldn't. We follow his
teachings.
said that you should get crucified like
like you claim he did. I didn't say
that, but that that entails that as
well. We don't have to do everything
Jesus did. We have to follow his
teachings. We follow his commandments.
We don't have to do everything he did.
But does he not say, and I know this
verse is going to get You we're going to
start arguing about this for the next
whatever, but the verse about not doing
away with the old law. You're going to
say, "Well, he defined this He fulfilled
the covenant and the old law is done
away with." And I will say, "No, it's
not done away with until the heaven and
earth pass away." We're going to just
We're just going to No, no, no, let's
let's go with that. So So let's go with
that. Let's stick Let's stick with that
thought. So
um Jesus says that, you know, the law
won't pass away until all is fulfilled.
Um but you have an understanding that
it's still stand like it's cuz heaven
and earth is here, so the law is still
right It's still the law. It's still
what is applicable to us today, right?
That's what you're saying.
Correct. Let's go with that. And you're
saying that Paul changing the law goes
against what Jesus said that it can't be
changed until heaven and earth pass
away, right? Correct. Okay, cool. So,
let me go with you. So, are you saying
that whoever teaches that Jesus changed
the law cuz like that's This is where
Paul is claiming he gets it from, you
know, that he's under the law of Christ
or whatever. So,
whoever teaches that Jesus changed the
law is going against what he actually
said, right, and they're a false
messenger. Are you going to now try and
apply this to Islam? I'm just asking the
question on Paul. No, you're going to
You're going to play a trick on me.
You're going to You're going to do a
reversal on Islam, aren't you?
You've been watching Islam enough.
Repeat the question, yeah? Repeat the
question, yeah? If someone is teaching
that the law has been changed, are they
a false messenger? I am not going to
play your little game. I know where
you're taking this. I know where you're
taking this. I know where you're taking
this. No, if this is not If the answer
is no, Okay.
Okay. Okay, listen here. Listen. You
can't use this on Paul then if you if
you can't answer that question, my
brother. You know what the most
ridiculous thing is? Right. The fact
that you and Sam always attack Islam and
the prophet about matters like violence.
When a man I'm talking about Paul. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. When a man like Paul
literally murdered unalived one of the
apostles. All right, so are we switching
it now? Are we talking about I'm just
saying you guys are not consistent
whatsoever. You said You said that Paul
unalived one of the apostles. Yes. Where
do you get that from? What do you mean?
It's there in It's there. He stood at
Show me the verse. Listen, I will pull
it up for you. When Sebastian When
Sebastian was unalived, he was there and
he approved of it. Who is Sebastian,
bro? Oh my goodness. Okay, so this is
false? Yes, it's false what you're
saying. I would say you have a
misconception. I think that you're
talking about Stephen. Stephen was
stoned and Paul was present when he was
stoned. Yes, that's what I'm That's what
I said. He stood there and he They
placed the clothes at his feet and he
and it says he approved of it. But where
does it say that? Where does it say that
he's the one who but that took part I
never said that I I I never said that he
did it with his own hand. I said he
approved You said that he unalived an
apostle. That's what you said. I I I'm
going to a second. If you are there in a
group of people and you watch them
unalive somebody, Yeah. what would the
judge say when you get taken to court?
That That I'm an accomplice.
They placed the
Okay. No, no, no, no, no. They placed
the clothes at your feet and you say,
"Yes, I approve of this." What would the
judge say? I'm not guilty of the crime.
You can't You can't
He can't He can't uh
What's it called? I can't believe you're
saying this. What? Say what you just
said to me to Sam, yeah? Say what you
just said to me to Sam. Okay, so wait.
So So Scott, are we are we So, do you Do
you under You You got rid of the
misconception, right? Paul never I never
said I know that he did not physically
unalive him. But you
But that's what you said, though,
brother. You said that Paul unalived a
an apostle. That's what you said. So
that you Now you know that that's not
the case, right? That never happened,
right? Okay, I know the story, okay? You
know I know the story. You know I know
the story, right? You change You Do you
know? You You You You You named somebody
named Sebastian who is nowhere in the
Bible. And then you And you also said
that Paul an apostle. You don't know the
story, dude. I know the story. I've got
it in my brain. They unalived him and
they placed the clothes at his feet and
it says that he approved of it. All
right, then Paul unalived him, yes or
no? With his own hands, no.
All right, then. But he approved of it.
You are wrong. Okay, I agree. He
approved of his of his unaliving, but he
himself he didn't he didn't he didn't do
it. He didn't take part in that. Okay.
Now, go on to the matter of Stephen. Go
on to the matter of Stephen.
No, not Stephen. Not Stephen. Where's my
question to you, bro? Okay. If someone
is teaching that the law has been
changed,
Oh my god, you're back to this. Cuz you
want me to say you want me to say yes
cuz then you're going to fight I want
you to tell the truth. That's all. Go
on.
Cuz you you brought this up to go
against Paul.
Go on. Go on. Okay, so like you know, if
you're going to use this against Paul
No, I'm not using it against I'm
according to your faith I'm using it
against Paul. No, you're not No, you're
Okay, so Paul All right, look, let me
just ask you this. Go on then. Yeah, go
on. Go on. According So, what is the
standard that we're using? Is is my
faith
So so your faith judged by whether
whether or not somebody's a true
messenger or not? The question you're
about to ask that you asked is if
someone comes and
abrogates on the law, is this person a
false messenger, yeah? That's the
question.
I'm I'm going to answer you, but I don't
want you to interrupt cuz I want to be
very clear. All right. The answer cuz
you want me to say the Prophet Muhammad
because you want me to say yes so that
you can say ah the Prophet Muhammad did
it as well, okay? But listen very
clearly. The answer is only yes if
another revelation is not revealed by
Allah. Okay? So if you are living in So
if you are living in a time, for
instance, let's say the first century
AD, okay? And the revelation has come
through Jesus Christ. Uh-huh. And then
someone like Paul comes along or someone
else and attempts to abrogate on it,
okay? This person would be a false
messenger cuz the revelat- the latest
revelation has come. Now, we obviously
believe that the Prophet Muhammad
received another true revelation later
on. So if any of this information is not
the same as what is found in
Christianity or Judaism, this is not an
abrogation because this is a replacement
revelation. Does that make sense? This
is a
a cleaning of the situation. Does that
make sense? No. Okay, all right. Well,
Let me Let me go with you. So, as long
as the abrogation comes by revelation of
God then then it's cool. Right?
Yeah, that's what I would say. That's
what I would say. I got you. I got you.
So look, here's uh Galatians chapter 1
verse 11. It says verse 11 and 12, "For
I would have you know, brothers, that
the gospel that was preached by me is
not man's gospel. For I did not receive
it from any man, nor was I taught it,
but I received it through a revelation
of Jesus Christ." So, what Paul is
teaching is a revelation. Right. So, So
therefore, if he's if he's reveals that
there's some laws that have been
abrogated, he's in the clear cuz it's a
revelation from God. Okay, you know
Thomas Aquinas used to tell people he
could levitate, right?
So, Right? There's a lot of bullshitters
in history, you know that, right? Do you
see how Paul meets all your criteria,
all your standards? What criteria does
he meet? Revelation. First of all, do
you agree or disagree that in order for
a man to receive revelation from God,
and you believe Christ is God, that he
ought to be pure? No. Oh, so Oh my. So
you don't believe that Jesus was I mean,
who is Jesus? Jesus is the only pure one
that's ever walked this earth. Everybody
else has failed. They've fallen short of
the glory of God.
Do you believe a man who is completely
corrupt can receive divine revelation? I
believe that a man I think that all men
are completely corrupt. That's what the
Bible says.
Completely corrupt.
No one is good except God alone. Okay,
yeah, you believe in faith You mean You
believe in You mean You believe in
salvation through faith. But honestly,
Do you believe in salvation through
Allah's mercy?
Uh yes, but we also believe in actions
and our actions here in this life as
well and our actions Yeah, but the we I
do too. I believe in actions this life
that my works are proof of my faith.
Wouldn't you say that your works are
proof
What What do you mean your works are
your proof? Where are you getting that
from? Which Which denomination are you
following now? The Bible. Look. Look.
And and by the way, this is what This is
again what Paul says. See? I'm showing
you that you actually agree with a lot
of the a lot of things that Paul
teaches. Watch this.
What would I agree with what Paul
teaches? I'm not Paul said circumcision
was not required. Paul said you could
eat pork. Wait. Wait. Wait. Paul Paul
Paul
Paul Paul established one sec. Paul
established his own church. Let me Dude,
relax. Let me You know what's You know
what You know You know what's terrible?
You guys don't look into the history of
Christianity.
you. Let me show you.
So this is what you This is what you
This is what you would agree with. For
For by grace you have been saved through
your faith, and this is not your own
doing. It is a gift from God. Not result
of works so that no one may boast. Do
you believe that God's mercy is as a
result of your works or is it a result
of his own goodness and mercy? It's I
believe the latter. Exactly. That's what
Paul just said. So, and then he says, he
goes on to say, "Not a result of works
that no one may boast."
But I But that's But But that's a That's
a That's a bit of a word salad. Can I
explain why? A word salad? Do you know
what a word salad is? Because of course
I do. And listen, God logic, let me
respond. The reason that's a bit of a
That's a bit of a play on words is
because a God can always God's mercy is
always um
uh Can you repeat the second part of
what you said the sec- the second
statement? The um the And this is And
this is not of your own doing. It is the
gift of God, not a result of works so
that no one can brag. No one can brag.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So So So we we we all
believe that God Allah is all powerful.
And so his mercy is is is is is his
alone, okay? So So the the point about
like you know, can Allah, you know, or
God give you mercy versus works is not
really like a It's not a dichotomy
between one another. You know what I
mean? It's not either or. It's you know,
both and. Beautiful. Nice. Let me
continue. Because God is all powerful
God. Good. Now listen, let me continue.
So Paul just highlighted how God has
given us grace by our faith.
Listen, let me ask you something. Wait.
Wait. Let me finish, bro. Goodness. Let
me show you how he continues to also
talk about your works. He says, "For we
are his workmanship, created in Christ
Jesus for good works, which God prepared
beforehand that we should walk in them."
We should walk in good works. So yes, uh
we God has given us his grace and mercy
because of our faith, and because of our
faith our response is to now walk in
good works. He has prepared us for good
works. Okay, but how does this How does
this address We can talk about this all
day, but how does this address the fact
that Paul said you don't need to get
circumcised?
Wait. Wait. Do you agree with what
Wait. I I I brought you here to show you
that you agree with Paul's teaching.
Don't you agree with this? Listen, on
the matter of Allah's mercy, God's
mercy, I agree that Allah's mercy is
above all, okay? Nice.
And I also And I also as a Muslim
believe that my actions in this life
determine my judgment in the year after,
okay? That doesn't make any sense. It's
It's either It's either your It's either
you're you're you're solely reliant upon
Allah's mercy.
it's not either or. It's not either or.
It is. It's not either or. It is. It's
either Your works get you your works
earn you God's mercy I I Can I get
Here's an analogy.
Here's an analogy, okay? Here's an
analogy, okay? Here's an analogy. You
have
two football players trying to get a
scholarship, right? And they both they
both score the exact same on a test to
get into to get into university, right?
But the principal looks at one of them
and says, "His mother recently passed
away, and so I will give him the
scholarship." They both did the same
works, but the mercy is what granted one
the passing over and not the other,
okay? So you can't have both. You can
have And it had nothing to do with their
works. No. Their works is what allowed
them to be in that position in the first
place where such a judgment could come
into play, okay? So if you don't have
any good works, you're saying that Allah
won't give you mercy? Allah is is all
merciful. So, if you do not have good
works, can you still earn his mercy?
Yeah, yes because we don't believe
people can We don't believe people can
We don't believe in eternal For some
people and for certain others, we don't
believe everyone goes to hell forever.
Okay, no worries. But you just Notice
what you just did. You just told me that
you said
Let me finish. Let me finish. You just
told me that even if a person doesn't
have good works, Allah is all merciful
and can still grant that person mercy.
Yes, BECAUSE HE IS ALL POWERFUL. SO it
shows you it shows you that it's not
dependent on your works. It's dependent
on his decision
and his mercy whether he shows mercy or
not.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. So good
works is irrelevant. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. This is such a word play. I gave
you an example. I gave you I gave you I
gave you an anal- This is your problem.
This is the Christians' problem. You
philosophize too much. You enter into
philosophy too much, and what happens is
you enter into
You cannot apply logic to matters like
this. It's not either or. It's not a
logic gate in a computer, one or
zero. One or zero. Okay?
Language. Language. Language. Listen.
Listen. Philosophy does not apply here.
This is theology, okay? Throw philosophy
out of the window, okay? Shove it up
some other person's okay?
Forget philosophy.
You don't even know that you just
philosophized when you said that. I know
I did. You began to philosophize once
you said we don't need we don't use
philosophy in this. You're You're using
philosophy when you say that. No, you
are not. Rejection of philosophy is not
philosophy, okay? Yeah, it is. No, it
isn't. This is This is why I know you're
stuck in philosophy cuz you even think
if someone rejects philosophy they're
philosophizing. This is how stuck in
philosophy you are. Do you know people
who have a PhD in theology? Yes, I know
personally, yeah. Do you know what PH
stands for? Yes. What? Yes, I do. What
What does it stand for? What does the P
stand for? The PH, what does it stand
for? What does it stand for? Philosophy.
Yes.
They have their philoso- the the They
have their their philosopher doctorate
in theology. Yes, because all of modern
You can't separate it. Philosophy is in
everything. You always use philosophy,
always. Okay, so does God use
philosophy? Yes. Well, God's a
philosopher. It begins with him. Why do
you think we have it? Philosophy comes
from God.
Listen Listen The The reason The reason
the the philosophy is in the P, okay?
Being serious for a second, is because
ancient systems all started with
philosophy and everything else branched
out from it, okay? So, all new
scientific fields and all new linguistic
fields, etc., all came from philo-
philosophical schools of thought, okay?
And then they branched out. But we don't
need philosophy God logic. You just
destroyed it again.
Oh my Anyway, listen, right? On the
matter of Paul, is it because you don't
want to get circumcised? Can you just be
honest? Where does it Wait. Where does
the Quran mention circumcision?
What are you talking about? Where does
the Quran say that you have to get
circumcised? I get it from the Hadith.
Show me. Show me Show me where it says
Google it. Google it. There's a Hadith
from the prophet where he says it's a
law for men to be circumcised. Google
it. Google it. Okay, was Muhammad
circumcised? What do you mean? Are you
crazy?
Was Muhammad circumcised? What do you
mean? Are you crazy? Muhammad,
at when he was 8 days old, get snip.
Listen. What do we believe? You know
what we believe? You know what What do
you believe? You know what we believe?
I'm asking you a question. No, what do
you believe? That's what I'm asking.
What do you believe? We Well, I think
there's different schools of thoughts on
this. I think uh some Muslims believe
that he was born circumcised and others
believe that he was was circumcised
later or I don't He was born
circumcised? I'm not I'm I'm not
educated on the matter of the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
matter of circumcision.
So, I'm not going to argue from
ignorance here. Listen, this is why you
know This is why you know that I am not
a dishonest liar. You know I'm not a
dishonest liar. I tell you when I'm
ignorant about a topic. I am ignorant on
the matter
But here's Here's the thing. Here's the
thing. You know what I like is that the
reason why we have
Listen. Listen. God logic, listen.
You have diverted the entire
conversation since I joined about into a
matter about Islam. No, I haven't. Yet
you know it says in the Bible very
clearly about the day on which Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, was
circumcised. Yes or no? We know Was Was
Muhammad circumcised? What? This is
irrelevant. We're talking about Paul.
because you're saying that in You're
You're You're in line with the with the
law. And if Paul is out of line with the
law or teaching you how the other then
Muhammad, if he's not circumcised, he's
not in line with the law and therefore
is a false prophet. God logic, listen,
bro. Listen. Bro, see you you you're not
being like you're not arguing in good
faith here, okay? Oh, ho. I never joined
this live to discuss Islamic principles
or Islamic history. I joined to showcase
to you why Paul ab-
What are we looking at, too? I I am
trying to showcase to you how Paul
abrogated from Jesus' life,
okay?
Uh-huh. And then And that makes him
wrong, right? And And yes. Okay, so
whoever All right. Now, let me ask you
this. I already clarified this. If
someone abrogates from Jesus' life, are
they a false prophet? Not if another
revelation is revealed.
All right.
We already clarified and I already read
to you that Paul received revelation.
So, so okay. He He meets your He meets
your standard. Okay, so so So, let me
ask you this then, okay? You believe
Jesus You believe he is crucified. He
ascends. He tells the
uh disciples to spread the word, okay?
And then you believe some decades later
this man who was a Roman Decades?
Decades is a few years later. Okay,
listen. Don't get into this with me cuz
you're going to lose, okay? I think I've
been winning this whole time.
Show me a single first-century papyrus
of the writings of Paul. Go on. What?
Show me a single first-century papyrus.
Doesn't Does that mean
Wait a second. Does that mean that his
writings don't come from the first
century? They don't. Really?
We know that the majority of the all
come from the early second to
mid-centuries, okay?
Okay. All right. Do me a favor. Do me a
favor.
Go online and put in the date of First
Corinthians. Yeah, I know what it says
the date is, but there is no extant
papyrus which proves it. Oh, so it it if
if they don't have a first-century
papyri- papyri manuscript, how do you
think they came to the conclusion that
Paul's letters date to the first
century? Because that's what the early
church fathers claimed in the second and
third centuries.
Well, they I'm not talking about church
fathers. I'm talking about liberal
scholars, people who are not Christians,
who are textual critics.
And and they even They even conclude
that Paul's writings date to the first
century. Why? If we don't have a
first-century document? Because they
take matter They They read people from
the second century
and they use that as the source, but it
is not It is not enough secondary It's
not enough to actually determine whether
or not Paul came a few years later,
okay? But But what is that
But they've determined this. Let's
assume he did. Let's assume he did.
Because actually Because actually
actually you're making my argument even
better by assuming such a thing.
Okay. So, let us Let us assume that Paul
came some years later, very soon after
Christ's crucifixion, okay? He He was
right there right after Christ's
crucifixion. He was
right there.
He He goes there and he meets with James
and he meets with Peter and blah blah
blah, okay? So, let's assume it was very
soon after. Yeah. My question to you is
the son of God, according to you, the
revelation, why would God simply a few
years later install a completely new
revelation? This is what you are
claiming now. You are claiming that God
brought his son, crucified him, and then
literally a few years later comes along
with an entirely new revelation which
goes against the law. Now, do you
realize why this is illogical? Do you
realize why this makes no sense? Do you
realize
You just destroyed the Quran.
Because if Paul coming with a new
revelation a few years later proves that
he's a false prophet and it doesn't make
logical sense, then how much more does
that disprove Muhammad as a false as a
prophet when he comes 600 years later
after Jesus? It proves him more. Why
does it prove him more? I'm what?
Because What are we doing, man?
Because the disciples at the time were
who met Jesus, who lived with him, who
supported him and protected him, they
were alive. They could spread the
message. It was still in them. It was
still alive. It was in their brain.
However, 600 years later, the prophet
was living around the time where it was
a bunch of pagan dirt-dwelling kafir,
okay? And that way God came along just
as he came to Moses and gave them gave
him the correct message.
Why Why Why 600 years after Jesus
though? That make If that If coming If
Paul coming a few years after Jesus
with a revelation makes him false, it
doesn't make logical sense for him to
come a few years after,
then it it doesn't make sense for
Muhammad to come 600 years later with a
with a
explained to you why it makes sense. Did
you listen to what I said? No, it it
doesn't make sense to me at all. You're
not being consistent. What do you mean?
I just explained to you why. Because the
disciples were alive. Peter was alive.
James was alive. The brother of Jesus
was alive. Why is IT THAT HE HAD HIS OWN
CHURCH.
IT GOT destroyed and Pauline
Christianity survived. He built up a
network of people and people he sent
letters to and and English James'
ministry was never destroyed. What are
you talking about? Okay, where is it
today? It's It's It's Christianity,
dude. Oh, it's Christianity, which
contains Where Where are all of James'
writings? Why doesn't James'
Why Why doesn't James' writings make up
a third of of of the document? Because
he didn't write a third of the New
Testament. Okay, so you're claiming it's
alive today yet it doesn't exist. Yet
you claim that Paul James' James'
religion was Christianity, bro. He We
have his letters. Did James eat pork? Uh
not to my knowledge. I don't know. Was
he circumcised? Yes, he was. Okay,
khalas. Finished. So, you have a
situation You have a situation where the
disciples, Jesus, his brother, his
family, they're all circumcised. They
don't eat pork. This man who killed one
of them comes along and he and he and he
and then literally a few years later,
according to you, and defines
so what would you say, Scott? Would you
say that whoever disagrees with James
is a false prophet then?
I don't know. I'm not well educated
enough to just answer that question.
But But you You know, you said it's
khalas. It's over with. When I met you
mean Do you not believe that James is
more of a reliable source than Paul?
Absolutely not. I believe I believe
they're equal. Did James meet Jesus?
Yep. Did Paul meet Jesus? Yep. No, he
No, no, no, no, no, no. Oh, okay. Well,
let me I got you. I got you. I I got
you. So, if someone didn't meet Jesus,
would that make them a false messenger?
No, but it makes them less reliable.
No, no, no, no. It makes them less
reliable.
you. I got you. I got you. So, it
doesn't necessarily make them a false
messenger, but it doesn't It makes them
less reliable if they never met Jesus.
Is that correct? Yes, compared to
someone who did meet Jesus, it makes
them less reliable. Beautiful. Did
Muhammad meet Jesus? What do you mean?
Did Muhammad meet Jesus?
explained to you he received revelation
from God. I And I already explained to
you that Paul received revelation from
God. No, because I explained to you that
you Wait Wait Wait Wait, Scott. Now I'm
going to your new argument that you
brought, that you have to meet Jesus in
order to have a certain level of
reliability. So, did Muhammad meet
Jesus? We are simply talking now. We're
not talking We're not talking theology
here. We're talk we're talking history.
what we talking philosophy now? We're
talking history  theology here,
okay? And philosophy, right? Mix it all
together and make a nice nice curry for
yourself, mate. Listen, all right? Cuz I
know you like that nice Shake Shack and
that Chick-fil-A you got over there in
the U.S.
And I know that you and Sam Shamoun, you
love to eat Chick-fil-A, you love to
You need to stop eating In-N-Out. I was
watching you.
Shake Shack and In-N-Out? Boy, you
you've been watching me. You got cameras
in here?
I watch you. Every day I think about how
I'm going to cook you. I'm going to fry
you, I'm going to put you in an In-N-Out
burger, bro. Every day every day. I'm
Middle Eastern, okay? You never know,
one day you might be a doner kebab.
Listen, right let me finish, right?
Listen, bro. Okay, listen listen listen
listen. Listen very clearly, okay? All
right. From a historical perspective,
the disciples, they are there. They
follow these laws. Paul comes along. He
adopts the faith. He claims he saw Jesus
on the road to Damascus, okay? No other
second-hand accounts of this matter,
whatever. Let's assume he did see him.
Let's even believe he Let's Let's
believe him. Let's believe him he did
see him, okay? Does it make sense
logically that this man who is still
alive, he meets Peter. He rebukes Peter
for not eating with the Gentiles. This
man who is still alive becomes and he
comes along and he provides this
revelation. Does this make any sense to
you? Sincerely, does this actually make
sense to you? It makes perfect sense to
me that Paul, being sent by Jesus, uh
wrote a lot of letters explaining the
gospel and breaking it down, speaking
from revelation since he says it's a
revelation from Jesus. Peter, James, and
John affirming that he's a messenger of
Jesus and that he's a messenger to the
Gentiles. They affirm him.
Who says Hang on a second. Whoa. Peter
even says that his his that Paul's
writing is scripture. Did you know that?
Okay, so on whose account? Peter's.
Okay. Okay. Go ahead and read the
source. Okay.
I'm familiar I'm I'm by the way I'm
familiar with the source, by the way.
I'm familiar with the source. I'm
familiar with the letters of Peter. I'm
familiar. So, let's go to what Peter
says himself about Paul's writing. Let's
see here. You can cook me now if you
want. I'll come back tomorrow with even
more seasoning for you, okay?
Okay, I'm with I'm with that, man. I'm
with that. I'm with that. I'm with that.
This is 2 Peter, chapter 3. I'm going to
start at verse 14. It says, "Therefore,
beloved, since you are waiting for
these, be diligent to be found by him
without spot or blemish and at peace."
Talking about being when Jesus comes
back. "And count the patience of our
Lord as salvation, just as our beloved
brother Paul also wrote to you according
to the wisdom given to him." Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Which Peter is this?
This is 2 Peter. Okay, you have
literally referenced 2 Peter, which is
not even agreed upon by scholars that it
was actually written by him. Is he
agreed in Is he agreed in in THE CHURCH
HISTORY? OH.
OKAY. We have We have no reason to doubt
this. Even Peter says Do you Do you
admit that scholars do not agree that it
is written by him? There There are There
are scholars that that just that don't
believe that Peter wrote 2 Peter. There
are scholars who don't believe that
Matthew wrote Matthew. That doesn't mean
anything to me.
So So do you know what this is like?
Wait Wait let me finish. There are
scholars that believe that affirm that
that Peter wrote 2 Peter.
So, what are we doing here? I'm
appealing to authority? It's just like
It's just like come on, dude. What? It's
just like It's like Do you know what
it's like? It's like me saying to you,
um you know, um my this girl is in love
with me. And then I write And then I get
a letter that my friend wrote that that
I that claims to be from her and I say,
"Look at the letter, she told me she
loves me." Do you know what I mean? No,
I don't see how that's relevant here.
Well, there's no evidence that the girl
wrote the letter, is there? Yes, we have
scholarship and church fathers, church
history. Oh, yeah?
There's nothing that points to the
opposite. Nothing that points to to the
other. Okay, can you Who Who quotes 2
Peter in the early church father
history? I I haven't looked at that
specifically. I don't have that info.
All right. All right. Well, um listen, I
think we're done here. Okay. And I I
love you. I love you. You are a
Christian. You're a You're you know,
you're part of the people of the book.
And
unfortunately, you hang around with Sam
who is bald and you have hair, so he's
jealous of you. You know
that all the time. Yes, that's true. But
But But listen listen listen. When are
you going to get circumcised? Why are
you worried about my junk? When are you
going to get circumcised? Why are you
Why are you worried about what what I
got in my pants, dog? I'm just saying,
listen. I'm just saying, listen. It's
there. Jesus circumcised, why didn't
you? Why you dodging? Oh.
You're just moving the goalposts every
time. This is what
I know, I'm using I'm using the same
goalpost. No, you're If Muhammad is a
follower of Jesus and in line with
Jesus' teachings and actions, why didn't
Muhammad get circumcised? Why don't you
work as a goalkeeper in soccer because
the way you move goalposts, it's
beautiful. It's honestly beautiful how
you keep switching the goalposts around.
No one would score against you. Uh
But listen, I genuinely I love you. I
hope Listen, why don't you come to
Speakers' Corner and me and you chat to
Muhammad Ali Jab and all them. I know
you don't like them. I'll be there again
soon. I don't I don't I don't know
exactly when again, but um I I plan to
go before the year is out. So, I'll
announce Well, I don't think I'll
announce it cuz I want people to make
sure that they're there. I don't want
people avoiding me. But
I'll try to message you and No one will
harm you. Don't worry, yeah? Don't worry
about
harm.
I said avoid. I don't want people
avoiding me. Oh, no. No one's going to
avoid you. I'm going to be there, bro.
I'll be there before you're even there.
I'll be at the airport, bro. And I'll be
there with a sign that says God Logic
ready to pick you up, take you to the
mosque, and you know, sort you up, all
right? I'll I'll definitely go to the
masjid. I'm down for that. All right. I
love you, bro. Love you, too, man. Okay.
Take care of yourself, all right?
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykumu s-salam.
All right, we'll see. All right. Now
slowly